if you're heading out of Britain you
won't get anywhere without a passport
the island is part of the EU but not
part of the passport free Schengen zone
but there are still plenty of people
going to mainland Europe many going by
ferry although it takes longer for the
ferry because Dover is currently
expanding its ferry port to create more
space for Freight incidentally using
funds from the EU until the Eurotunnel
was completed just under 20 years ago
ferries like the MS spirit of britain
were the only link with the european
mainland but captain robin bent and his
crew still have no shortage of work
despite competition from the tunnel
whichever is the cheaper way to go
that's where the truck drivers and the
truck companies want to go so there was
always competition on the freight rates
so if we if we're providing a good
freight rate I mean they'll come with us
if the tunnel provides a better Freight
rate they will take and it fluctuates
all the time so there was always a
little bit of a war on he's paying the
best who's charging the best rate to get
a freight to peace across the channel
what makes the crossing expensive is the
fuel for huge engines power the spirit
of Britain's consuming six tons of
diesel for every crossing and if the
crew is running late they have to up the
speed causing the engines to work faster
and use even more fuel
around thirty kilometers of sea separate
Britain from the mainland the natural
border gives the captain a feeling of
security I like to see borders between
countries because we are all different
still after 30 years of working on this
route he supports the European idea it
just feels like a unity like a complete
family if he like we do only joined
forces with Europe many many years ago
and I think it works an outreach I think
I had trade proves it working closely
with France for these ferries to go back
with support in the past most of his
passengers were tourists and in the
summer months the passenger deck is
still full but the main business now is
the freight trucks mostly carrying
British products for mainland Europe the
crossing takes 90 minutes and then the
cargo arrives in Cali the company is
even thinking of buying new ferries
presumably that would only be worthwhile
if Britain maintains its close trade
links with the rest of the EU
Gendry scatter around Europe you know
South to trot even far Cyprus
don't stop down the cyclist there and
back and
some libya morocco algiers
the majority of it before we find these
perishable goods the ferry only stays in
Calais for forty-five minutes
not long enough for the crew to get out
to see anything on the French side the
ferry sales every day around the clock
after the brief stop to take on new
passengers and trucks the spirit of
Britain heads back to Dover